hello again and welcome to agilent's
energy and chemical virtual seminar
our next presenter is paul barboni paul
is our gc analyzer product manager
uh he's based in wilmington and delaware
in our
gc r d facility paul's going to be
presenting
a range of pre-configured analyzers
designed to meet testing needs for
quality
and safety in the oil and gas processing
industry
during paul's presentation uh if you
need any more information or if you have
any questions you'd like to ask us
the toolbar at the bottom of the
auditorium is a great place to
ask us those questions or if you have
any technical problems
and we can fix those for you straight
away so
without further ado i'll hand over to
paul
hello and welcome to our comprehensive
suite of pre-configured gas analyzers
from agilent
the innovator in gc
while agilent has a diversified and
well-established
background in gas chromatography we
can't really appreciate the value of the
analyzer part of the offering without
understanding how it fits into the
larger gc
category founded in 1939 by bill heward
and dave packard
in this modest garage in california the
company would become agilent
now has over 50 years of experience in
gas chromatography
one of our core businesses we have
established ourselves as the global
leader
in gc in terms of innovation
quality and wholesale support
this is the biggest strength of an
agilent gc analyzer
it's the agilent gc we have a deep
knowledge pool of factory and field
personnel
who build upon the already strong
agilent gc
which is where the value of a gas
analyzer is recognized
it's that applied knowledge combined
with a strong foundation
and reputation of the base agilent
gc here we see a
brief timeline of the agilent history
that i referred to
agilent was born from hewlett-packard in
1998
and you may be familiar with the
high-end lab gc
product line history of 5890
6890 7890
and now the 8890 gc gas chromatographs
history of high-end lab gcs are just a
part of the overall
agilent gc portfolio you can find more
details on a poster of this gc timeline
at our agilent.com website and i
would encourage you to do so there are a
lot more details of gc innovation there
the point is that we build agilent gc
analyzers on the best possible
foundation
on the world that that's the agilent gc
from there we add some special hardware
and sometimes software or reports
so that someone can receive delivery
from our factory
and start seeing meaningful results
without having to perform
additional hardware or reporting
modifications to define what we mean by
gas analyzer as
established we start with the gc from
agilent
and then add hardware and features like
specific
gas flow paths inlets detectors
columns and valves to control
flow path with details like a back flush
or a column isolation this unique
hardware is then optimized at the
agilent factory
for method development on specific
serialized
gcs on that order
that optimization is then shipped with
the gc
in electronic format and duplicated
by the certified agilent service
representative
when the system is installed
many but not all of the gc analyzer
models
fit energy and chemical applications
often these gcs perform the same short
method
over and over and it's very purpose
built
in this application range there are
components that could be corrosive to
hardware or poisonous to columns
so complex plumbing is often
incorporated
to provide back flush or column
isolation
refinery gases and natural gases are a
big part of the energy
in chemical applications the separations
aren't that complicated but keeping the
analytes of interest in the columns and
detectors they should use
and away from other parts of the system
that the sample matrix might harm
requires complex flow path plumbing and
very exact timing of events
setting up all of this at the factory is
a big part of the analyzer value
we can also match gc configurations to
publish methods
such as astm uop or gpa
methods in addition to the refinery and
natural gas analyzers
agilent has offerings for the
pre-configured analyzers
for biofuels for multiple astm
and en standards including headspace
applications
there are also gc analyzers that use
hardware
ancillary to the gc like mass spec or
headspace
using the 8890 gc there are options for
mass spec
analyzers for several pesticide analyses
and headspace sampling is available on
the 8890 gc
and the intuvo 9000 gc notably
transformer oil gas analyses for the
electrical generation
and delivery industry as well as blood
alcohol testing
and residual solvent pharmaceutical
testing
agilent gc analyzers are tested at the
factory
with the open lap suite of data systems
and also the mass spec software mass
hunter
these methods which are saved to a dvd
that ships with the system
are then confirmed by the installing
engineer
with the same checkout standards used at
the factory
as an overview of our portfolio
here we see some details about the
standard models offered
many are fid and tcd combinations
often in the parts per million range
there are some
options for sulfur matrices some for
nitrogen
carrier gas and many are focused on
analytes
c6 or lower this also calls out the
opportunity for
customization we have standard model
designs
but can accommodate a significant amount
of
customization so please work with your
agilent
application engineer to go over the
options
for customization
a great resource in addition to your
agilent application engineer
is the agilent.com website there are
more details on gc analyzers
under the solutions subheading and
there's also a lookup tool
for publish methods
thank you very much for more application
on any of the gc analyzer information we
just covered
please contact your agilent
representative
so thank you to our presenter for that
great presentation and thank you for
watching
please if you have any feedback on the
presentation on the topic
on on the content uh the toolbar at the
bottom
there's the option to give us feedback
if you'd like any more information
on the solution and product in the
presentation again
if you ask us here we'll get that
information to you
and uh yeah if if you have any questions
please i use the web chat function or or
give us that feedback and we'll
reply as soon as we possibly can thank
you again for watching